linda evangelista is making headlines
for regretting changing up her look with
the doctor's help and linda's not the
only one tonight e.t examines the stars
racked with remorse after a cosmetic
procedure
[Music]
versace won't want to dress me with that
sticking out of my body
linda claimed she is permanently
disfigured due to a rare reaction from a
popular fat freezing procedure called
coolsculpting the issue is that it's a
very rare but unfortunate complication
where rather than eliminate or shrink
some of the fat cells it actually does
the opposite
the former supermodel unveiled those
masses of fat cells to people and is now
suing for 50 million dollars i had some
plasticity that i wasn't happy with
and when you're not happy with yourself
physically it's hard to be happy inside
in 2004 sharknado star tara reed
suffered a humiliating red carpet
wardrobe malfunction that revealed her
botched breast implants so tara reed's
nipple shape is a potential complication
now the majority of patients it heals is
a nice thin line but in her case it
widened and it gave that boxy shape to
the areola
tara ended up having corrective surgery
and regained her confidence
so i think once i fix myself physically
i just feel
completely better about myself
i have regrets of getting so many
procedures
in 2010 the hills new beginnings star
heidi montag was just 23 years old when
she underwent 10 procedures in one day
including breast implants a brow lift a
nose job and chin augmentation
it's just an impulsive decision that i
was too young to make that was one of
the lowest points in my life
in 2014 law and order svu star stephanie
march suffered an infection from her
breast augmentation it got so bad the
seam on her right breast burst i believe
it was an allergic reaction which is
true in
one percent of the people who have the
surgery
janice dickinson told e.t she believes
her implants may have made it harder to
spot her breast cancer diagnosis
if i had to play my life over again i
would have never gotten breast implants
in the first place
one of this year's oscar hosts amy
schumer recently revealed the results of
getting liposuction which she loves but
a month earlier the comic had cheek
fillers dissolved saying quote i looked
like maleficent
listen is the risk worth the reward
that's up to the patient can it happen
yes does it usually happen no
[Music]
you